you're a huge fan of
new kids on the block is that right i am
yeah new kids on the block okay settle
down everything i have been for a long
time absolutely no one went with you on
that um
no but no that's fine it's fine you're
just in the new kids on the block that
was your band when you were that special
age it was like new kid on the block new
kids on the block and
tears for fears
[Applause]
that was impressive that like it's the
same generation but they're not saying
anymore new kids on the block and then
they're going nuts for tears for fears
well maybe because tears for fears
doesn't tour as much right we're missing
them they should tour um okay what's
good i've been to several new kids
they've been touring a lot in the last
like five years so i try to see them as
much as i can
you posted uh a photo
because this is happening
yes i am actually yes and i know where
you live uh
you posted this photo which was taken a
few years ago when you were pregnant and
you're wearing your new kids on the
block shirt was this uh is this you by
the toilet yeah yeah yeah i was going to
say nice use of the toilet yeah
it's always good to have a toilet handy
you always look better if you pose next
to a toilet yeah
no one's
no one no modeling trope
that's why supermodels always pose near
toilets
because they look so much better
did you go prettier did you go pregnant
to a new kids on the block i did in that
picture i was about seven months
pregnant and i was wearing a property of
joy t-shirt that i had gotten at the
last
concert i went to when i wasn't pregnant
so it didn't fit as well kind of my
belly sort of hung out of it but
yeah i i went to the concert and we went
backstage and met the boys the men now
they're men um now they're in there what
are they how old are they now i think
they're in their late 30s early 40s
right yeah we we met them backstage i
was escorted by security backstage i
think they thought that we were getting
escorted out
because we looked a little crazy but um
we met them and
said hi and then during the concert i
was jumping around and screaming and i
started having contractions
and in new kids on the concert
so my sister said that if you have a
baby at any kids on the block concert i
will kill you so i had to sit down every
other song
right for her
every other song that was your big
contract your big concession i may be
giving birth i'll sit out one song but
now here comes the next one
i don't know any of their songs right i
don't wait for it to die down or if it
was a slow song i'd take a seat okay is
joey that was your favorite i don't know
who that is joey charlie gus yep yep
gus drax drucks drexel
simon and gustav i remember those were
the
i didn't i saw joey mcintyre at a
restaurant a couple weeks ago
really yep
it was pretty cool
totally geeked out we were both waiting
to get into this restaurant and we were
both there early
um
and so we chatted for a long time he had
a wife beater on his he's pretty ripped
he wore a what restaurant would you was
this a red lobster
no that's what's funny actually
restaurant whatever he's wearing a wife
beater
it's an all-you-can-eat shrimp you gotta
be honest hey joey get back to work i'm
getting back to work
so he's from boston i know he's from
boston he they made him put on a t-shirt
when he came in it was a houston's
restaurant they had a black t-shirt and
he got to keep it
wait they made him put on a t-shirt
nice restaurant yeah yeah so maybe he
wanted a free t-shirt yeah he did that
on purpose those new kids that's what
they're up to now
scamming free t-shirts left and right
hey boys let's get together right here
we can get some t-shirts he's a nice
teacher he's a nice okay uh poor guy
listen um